hello folks and welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics right
anyways regarding uh
extinction all i can tell you mr musk
says that the world economy
is going to hell he's a little worried
about that and so that's just food for
thought okay but let's get on with our
science critic there's a fellow who uh
made a video and he criticizes our site
our notion of science our notion of
physics
and i'm going to be addressing each one
of his points and the point he made
one of the points he made and i'm going
to talk about today is whether if you
have a phd
right
does that mean that you understand
physics
and so let me put them on here give me a
second okay let me turn this fellow on
here goes listen carefully
the issue to be resolved in this
rebuttal is
does having a phd in mathematical
physics imply that the individual
understands physics
well if you have a phd you're far more
likely to understand the subject that
you have a phd in than someone who
doesn't have a phd in that subject if
you've got a phd that at least shows
that you have a decent understanding of
the subject because you do need a decent
understanding of the subject to be able
to get a phd
okay so the question is whether you need
a phd to understand or we can put it in
different terms we can say that a person
who has a phd for example in so-called
mathematical physics right
whether he can understand things better
than
you
or anyone else
and i take exactly the opposite view
okay here's my uh rundown of that okay
these are what i call the fallacies
okay
first of all i think it's easier for an
eight-year-old to understand
physics uh than it is for anyone who's
gone through high school or college
and you might say well that sounds
counter-intuitive
and let me tell you why because see when
you get to high school when you get to
college they start feeding your brain
okay and uh when we come out of there
we come out and believe in for example
i'll give you a good example uh we
believe that
electricity consists of the flow of
electron beads from one atom to the next
that's is what required in his brain
he's not going to change his way of
thinking so easily on the other hand if
you take a
a kid you know eight-year-old kid
and you teach him the right way or you
teach him a different way from the start
you know he he's got no reason to
believe then that the you know
electricity is the flow of beats
so that's that's the key issue okay it's
that uh in in high school in college
they start forming our brains and then
it's very hard to get out of that i know
i've been there done that okay
so i call that the fallacy of authority
and that's what this is what it looks
like you have uh you could say big
brother there or someone with a big
degree teaching you and you learn by
rote and then you repeat what this
fellow told you
you believe it in great measure because
if you want to make a career
you know you do a career out of it for
example physics well you're not going to
get an advisor unless unless you know
you follow the rules and the rules is
you have to suck up
okay that's the issue
you know and uh i don't know how you can
get a degree unless you
uh
at least
you know uh follow the party line
okay you have to
be able to recite the catechism that's
what it amounts to
i call that the fallacy of authority
anyways uh here you have some phds this
is what they believe here are some
examples okay they have proposed big
bang
black hole
particle at two places at once
warp time
now how's that for for uh people who
have degrees
what their phds right we're talking
about the highest degree here
and
if this is what they came out with you
know i mean what does it tell you about
them
and this is what you gotta think about
so the way i look at a degree does not
necessarily equal to understanding in
fact i think it's the other way around
if you have a degree
typically it's because you've been
brainwashed in a given direction and
it's very very hard for you to you know
come out of that
and uh so you know just keep that in
mind when you go to college they
actually make you think in a given way
and
you know it's almost impossible for
people to come out of that
then there's the fallacy of democracy
what i call the
fallacy of democracy that's what it
looks like okay
uh everybody voting for a theory
and that's also more or less what's
happening at the college level you know
you have all these mathematicians on
planet earth and they vote for a given
theory and so people say well it's been
proven because all these mathematicians
believe in that theory
okay and so you have uh
you know theory someone says you know
particle and b of two places at once
and
if everybody votes for that uh because
they've studied quantum mechanics
and you say well you know that sounds uh
counterintuitive that doesn't sound very
irrational well they're going to say
that what you have to do is take a
course in college
so that you're brainwashed in the same
direction
so yeah you've got that situation as
well
and then uh the last one is what i call
the fallacy of tradition okay and that's
what it that looks like okay here it is
that's the policy of tradition you know
you you believe in stuff because that's
the way we've always done it
and a prime example are definitions
what people do with definitions is they
they you'll see them here on comments
that people make
and they go in there and they say look
uh this is the etymology of the word
i don't care what the etymology of the
word word is because those words were
created a long time ago maybe they come
from the latin from the greek from the
persian who knows from where
and they had a certain definition
centuries ago
we've changed many of those definitions
throughout time you know we've made
uh we've given new definitions to old
words
that's happened but all those
definitions are really in the realm of
ordinary speech
when you bring them into science
hopefully hopefully you restrict their
usage so that you know they don't cover
everything
out there so that you can't tell the
difference between a and b now you have
to make sure that you have a very crisp
definition that you can use consistently
that's called rational you know
scientific
and uh so yeah the fallacy of tradition
primarily relates to
definitions but it also the way we do
things one of the fallacies of
tradition also involves you know the
fact that
we have this notion of the scientific
method of science that we have inherited
from the 17th century
and we're not very willing to change
that we think we're on the right track
and it turns out that
not a single mathematician who follows
the so-called scientific method of the
17th century can tell you anything about
gravity they cannot tell you anything
about magnetism they can't tell you what
electricity is they can't tell you how
the atom behaves they can't tell you
what mediator
we have for light
in other words they can't tell you
anything about the invisible intangible
entities and mechanisms that mother
nature and father universe use out there
but they've been following the
scientific method now what for 400 years
so they're not willing to change that
and in fact i had a case this week
i was interviewed on thursday by a
fellow from england
and uh so i told him up front that i
have a different notion of what science
is i have a different notion of what the
scientific method is
and i told him up front that he would be
shocked because i was going to delete
from the scientific method i was going
to delete mathematics
and i'm going to delete also experiments
now he seemed to agree he kind of liked
the fact that i just you know took
mathematics out he didn't give me a
reason but he seemed to like that but
when we got to experiments
he had big troubles with that okay he
said you know you're going to remove
experiments i said yeah we don't need
them
we don't do experiments in science we
explain them
and so i
i really put them against the wall on a
given issue on a specific issue and i
said
you have
you know gravity
you let go of the pen i always do my
little experiment here let go of the pen
and it falls to the floor okay
you can't see or touch anything below or
above the pen
correct
and so the question is
what experiment
are you going to use meaning see
touch right eyes hands what experiment
are you going to run
to
elucidate
the
first the uh
entity that mediates gravity
and second be able to explain it because
you proposed a an entity that we can see
or touch
so there there is no way there's no
experiment you can run to detect the
invisible intangible the only way is to
use the mind you visualize
and you try to imagine how mother nature
father universe devil the god whoever
you believe in how they could be doing
this magic trick okay there is no
experiment you can run in the lab to
detect whatever is causing gravity and
that's just one example and so you know
i i told this fellow this
and again here we have the fallacy of uh
all these fallacies come back the
tradition uh democracy and specifically
you know the
the uh one the uh one of authority
people believe in authority this is what
they've been drilled
with
in high school and college and this is
what they regurgitate you know as again
the party line that's all it is that's
what it comes down to
and so uh this fellow he had troubles
with that and what was interesting that
um
we debated a little bit about some of
the definitions okay and these are some
of the definitions i found in his site
afterwards i checked his site and these
are some of the definitions he's got out
there and the the two that we're missing
are the two most important ones meaning
he wasn't even on track on figuring out
what are the most important definitions
that we need at least for the purposes
of physics and here let me show you what
definitions he proposed what i want you
to notice is that he mentions these
words
specifically the word exist
but he never defines it
but so when i tried to define exists he
had a problem with that because it was
contrary to what he believed in
uh he apparently was an atheist and he
had a problem with me saying that uh you
know an atheist
was not a rational individual because an
atheist talks about the non-belief of
god or that he doesn't believe that god
exists and then i told him is any
rational statement it's an irrational
statement because he doesn't understand
what the word exist means and physics is
the science of existence
so that's how it all works so here are
his definitions okay he says believe to
accept something as true
so he uses words such as true false
you'll find it in there i underline some
of these what is knowledge fact
truth okay
he talks about reality what is reality
well you look it up there that right at
the bottom reality is means
reality is that which exists well
unfortunately reality is a synonym of
exists so he hasn't defined the word
reality what he's done is he put a
synonym and uh and he goes around in
circles because again he hasn't defined
what exists means
so uh this is the issue and one of the
issues that
was interesting about his definitions in
that is that he uh referenced ain rand
ein rand as some caller i call her ain
rand okay
and when he mentioned there are two that
are really unimportant they're not
important as for example entity and
exist but he put in their concept okay
he said a constant is a mental
integration of two or more units
possessing the same distinguishing
characteristics with their particular
measurements omitted they are isolated
by a process of abstraction and united
by a specific definition
enran was very verbose
and
she made nonsense of the word concept
the other one is reason
and the problem is that reason uh she
divided is the faculty that identifies
and integrates the material provided by
man's senses
thinking is the process logic is the
method so
enran thought that census had something
to do with reason whether you're
sensible right
whether your sound whether your argument
is sound and when you look up all these
words uh you know they're all uh
synonyms sound sensible reason rational
they're all
synonyms so she never defined the word
because he used synonyms to define them
okay you can't do that in science
besides you synonyms are outlawed
because a synonym is
um
a circular definition or what i call
no definition at all okay
and uh this is another one that he had
here he because he um
as well suggested that there are things
that we know and i said we know nothing
because no means to believe when someone
knows
he believes
he believes for sure he's convinced of
whatever he believes in that's called
knowledge his knowledge could be
different than my knowledge so he gave
me an example and he said well we know
we know that water boils at 100 degrees
okay
and so this is the example you said
water boils at 100 degrees
and there's a couple problems here the
first one is that
i'm going to take the i'm going to play
devil's advocate okay
and i'm going to say uh no water does
not boil at 100 degrees and he said no
let me prove it to you let me show you
look we put some water here i heat it to
100 degrees and put and i say i don't
believe you
i don't believe i don't know your
knowledge
i i disbelieve you
and he goes in here no but listen let me
show you let me prove it to you here's
the truth here's the fact and i continue
to say no no no no and no what's he
gonna do kill me
i mean there are people who simply will
not change their minds no matter what
experiment what proof you present and
they will continue to believe otherwise
and he didn't understand that nowadays
is what one person has okay
and so
that's one issue the other issue is that
water boils at 100 degrees
that's not an explanation that's a
description that's a prediction he can
say look i did it a hundred times now i
can predict to you and i can run an
experiment where i prove to you that
water boils at 100 degrees
so far he hasn't explained anything all
he's done is describe what's going to
happen he hasn't told me why
what causes
water to boil at 100 degrees
so i gave him
a truth a fact a proof right the whole
works
um
you know something that's been confirmed
by experiment i said look nasa ran
gravity probe b what was that i think
1971 okay i think it was 71 72
thereabouts anyways nasa ran this
experiment
and what was the conclusion what was the
physical interpretation
for what they say is a com another yet
another confirmation of einstein's
theory okay what was the explanation
they said that the earth drags
drags time around itself it's known as
frame dragging okay and then we got a
little title for it because they're
saying that with respect to a given
frame frame of reference right uh
something changes they had these two
gyroscopes that changed their position
out there and they say oh we confirmed
it and we proved it etc etc and so i
gave him that explanation i said look uh
nasa says that
earth as it spins it drags time around
itself
which makes no sense whatsoever from a
physical point of view okay
mathematically we don't care we're
saying that the explanation they gave us
is is nonsense
and he says well i don't believe that i
said what do you mean you don't believe
it's knowledge we've proven it through
an experiment like you said
and he said no that knowledge i don't
believe i don't believe nasa
so so i mean again knowledge is what one
person believes okay the his neighbor
doesn't believe it okay
and he said but my knowledge is
justified you know that comes from plato
justified true belief okay and he said
but my what if it's justified what if i
have a justification for having that
knowledge
and i said justified means belief what
is justified who justified it the pope
the dalai lama i mean who justified it
justified means opinion belief so all he
said is he believes his belief that's
all he said when he says that his
knowledge is justified
so no those people who insist that
knowledge is different than belief well
i want a definition don't tell me that
you your knowledge is different just
tell me what each one exactly means
and i'll be glad to tear it apart
because to this day we equate well we
start we're still using plato's
definition
and that one uh it comes out as
justified true belief that's what
knowledge is and all they're saying is
that your belief is justified but what
is justified to one human being is
unjustified to another and knowledge
comes
down to being equal exactly equal to
belief there's no difference okay
experiment will not change that okay no
experiment will change that
okay so so uh what was this uh fellas uh
beef well the problem was when i said
that atheists are as irrational as
agnostics and as diaz or
theists
why why are these three groups uh
irrational
they're irrational because they never
defined the word exist
so they argue in circles one guy says i
believe that god exists and he presents
all his proof the other guy says i don't
believe that god exists and he presents
all his arguments and proofs and the
agnostic says well i don't know if god
believes or
exists or not
i don't know what tests we can run i'm
not sure what arguments they have beyond
them you know they have like several
arguments but essentially it's a guy who
hasn't made up his mind he's on the
fence and i'm saying all these three
individuals are irrational
why are they irrational
well for that we we go back to mrs ain
rand okay maybe she can clarify for us
why it's irrational here's a rand's uh
definition of entity first okay thing
what is a what is an object what is a
thing what is an entity she liked the
word entity no problem we considered it
a synonym okay
of object end of uh thing
so where's the problem let's let's look
at her definition we'll find out here it
is okay she says entity okay and she
says to exist is to be something
and we have a problem there as you can
see uh
uh she essentially uh was a
pupil uh a follower whether she knew it
or not of david hume and emmanuel kant
who said exactly the same thing in the
18th century because they couldn't tell
the difference between exist and a thing
or
exist and an object so she says to exist
is to be something absolutely not but
let's continue as distinguished from the
nothing of non-existence
it is to be an it is to be an entity of
a specific nature made of specific
attributes and this is where it goes
wrong i want you to listen to this
because she essentially synthesizes what
most people out there think a thing is
okay
the development of human cognition
starts with the ability to what perceive
things in other words entities perceive
it's that perception word that
introduces the observer
uh where we don't need them
and so she continued says of man's five
cognitive senses only two provide them
with the direct awareness of entities
sight and touch
exactly the ones that we kill we say
sight and touch have nothing to do with
physics okay we don't use sight and
touch when we theorize
we have to kill the observer we do it
mafia style rub the witness out that's
the way it works in science
in order to perceive this something he
needs sight and or touch
okay so she's going to emphasize the
observer she's going to emphasize the
witness she says we need sight and we
need hands touch we need eyes and hands
it is by perceiving entities that man
perceives the universe okay so she did
emphasize
uh that for entities for things
what you need is eyes and touch and what
is eyes and touch it's also exist
because exist is defined exactly in the
same way not only by ain ran but david
hume and emmanuel kent okay and so we
move to existence which is what concerns
us because we're going to be talking
about the atheists who say that they
don't believe in god we are looking at
the theists and theists who say they do
believe in god and the agnostics who say
that they don't know whether to believe
or not and this is what ayn rand had
said about existence
existence exists
exists now how's that for a definition
and the act of grasping that statement
implies two corollary axioms that
something exists which one what
perceives
and that one exists possessing
consciousness consciousness being the
faculty of what perceiving that which
exists
all she did was chase her tail around
if nothing exists there can be no
consciousness
a consciousness with nothing to be
conscious of is a contradiction in terms
okay if that which you claim to perceive
does not exist what you possess is not
consciousness
whatever the degree of your knowledge
these two existence and consciousness
are axioms you cannot escape whether you
know the shape of a pebble or the
structure of the solar system the axioms
remain the same that it exists and that
you know it again knowledge introduced
together with existence and things
so she continues she said to exist is to
be something absolutely not as
distinguished from the nothing nothing
of non-existence the greatest of
philosophers she was referring to
aristotle has stated the formula
defining the concept of existence and
the rule of all knowledge
a is a
a thing is itself existence is identity
now all she said was nonsense okay a is
a we talked about that the other day
is absolute nonsense the
identity the law of identity
and then you have the law of
non-identity which is a not equal b
i mean it's all nonsense now what we do
in science we have to define what an
object is and we have to define what
existence is once we define those words
we can start doing physics okay and so
some people confuse me with a rand and
those that do simply have not figured
out
how different my stuff is from what ain
uh
uh proposed
uh an object is that which has shape
existence is physical presence physical
means object presence means location and
object that has location exists by
definition and as you can see there's no
provision
in that definition nothing
there's nothing in the specification of
that definition that requires belief
or an observer if something has
is a
if you have an object that would just
shape and it has location it exists by
definition if god wants to exist
first he's got to be an object got to be
a thing and then that's not sufficient
either he's better have location there
had
better be distance between god's chest
and mind there should be a straight line
of direction between god and me no
matter where no matter what dimension
god wishes to hide in
okay
so let's go with the conclusions here
for this fellow okay
uh conclusions high school college
education what is that it's known as
brainwashing what they're going to be
doing is you're going to be learning by
road you read a book
maybe you even run an experiment at lab
it doesn't matter but they're going to
coach you on what to believe okay
and
what's the problem the problem is that
all that's accompanied by irrational
explanations
and they don't care about mechanisms
they haven't figured out any of the
invisible intangible mechanisms they
dismiss that as philosophy as opinion
and i can summarize it by saying you
can't teach an old dog
new tricks
no it's easier for an eight-year-old to
understand uh for example what i'm
proposing okay because
he his mind has not been polluted
so
a little boy who might be more
uh
predisposed
to understand a new theory than an old
dog you know who's gone to high school
and uh in college especially a phd who
has to
get an advisor for his thesis
that guy is not going to change
so i see it the other way around then
this
british fellow i'm saying that
if
you've
got a phd oh man you you've gone through
the whole machinery
they've been conditioning you for quite
a while you know so
if i go in there and say look i'm going
to erase the uh
scientific method that you inherited
from the 17th century
he's not even going to listen to me
okay let's move on to the gut what is
the gut the grand unified theory
what is known as the
holy grail
of mathematics
of mathematical physics okay here's a i
guess a rundown
so that you can follow along
okay the gut the holy grail of
mathematics
gut is what the unification of light and
gravity
you could also say it's the unification
of quantum mechanics and general
relativity general relativity is the
world of the big
we're talking about planets stars
galaxies and the
big issue there is gravity
and then you have the world of the small
and that typically involves light and
things like
electricity magnetism which could also
be applied you know on a global on a
universal basis
okay so uh what is math mathematical
physics it's uh equations followed by
irrational mechanisms okay not a single
one
of the mechanisms proposed by
mathematical physics is rational
what is
irrational the movement of concepts if
you start vibrating the field
if you start waving the wave
right
if you start um
transferring energy or moving the mass
well then it gets very very dangerous
okay
uh
so you know we we don't want to start
moving concepts around that's what they
do
and uh so that's what they're trying to
do they're they're trying to
merge
uh
light with gravity and general
relativity with quantum mechanics that's
the holy grail but what are they looking
at they're looking at an equation
they're trying to find this grand
equation that underlies it all that can
describe it all
because again they're not talking about
explanations they're not talking about
mechanisms and causes what they're
talking about is just a description a
numerical a quantitative description
okay
and that's what an equation does it
describes that's how it does so now
let's say we have some entity out there
we'll call it a
and uh what unidentified flying object
you like that one a ufo okay
its speed is 30 miles per hour so what
are we talking about are we talking
about a turbo car are we talking about a
galloping cheetah
are we stretching a spring a coil
you're looking at the front end of the
coil is that what's traveling at 30
miles per hour
or is it flowing water are we having a
liquid
flow there
and here let me give you
an example
okay here it goes okay look at him he
goes everywhere
so what are we staring at we're seeing
what a tornado there what what is that
so the first thing you need to identify
is the thing that is moving
unless you can identify the thing you
know what are you describing
okay this is the problem and right now
we don't have uh entities for the
invisible intangible mediators
that mother nature uses out there
so the fact that you can tell me how
fast your turbo car goes or your
galloping cheetah or your or when you
stretch a coil it doesn't tell me which
of these
you are referring to because the
equation applies equally to any of those
situation in any of those contexts so
the issue is there
that you need to identify the invisible
intangible entities that mother nature
uses and that's what they've never done
in uh
in mathematical physics that's why we
don't have
explanations of mechanisms today what we
have is equations we have descriptions
we have predictions but we don't know
what's causing it
and you know for 3000 years people have
asked the same question what causes
gravity
a little sooner than that you know what
causes magnetism what causes electricity
i mean what was fair day investigating
what was uh maxwell investigating they
were trying to figure out how this
universe works and by how i don't mean a
description like saying oh it works at
such and such speed or this is the
acceleration or whatever no they were
trying to figure out what causes it
what are we staring at why does a pen
fall to the floor that's what they were
trying to figure out what causes that to
happen and here let me give you a good
example here we have the lines of force
of a magnet okay
and uh they say well this is a what we
call a magnetic field magnetic field is
made out of all these lines of force as
mr faraday told us
and so when you look at this they say
you know they try to explain that they
say well we those lines of force don't
really exist
we use them just to uh give you some
sort of physical interpretation
of what's going on there but they don't
really they're not really there
you know so you have all these iron
filings they line up around the magnet
and they form those uh familiar patterns
and they say well don't pay attention to
that because those lines of force are
not really there
and so you say well why does a magnet
attract another and they start talking
about the field you know they start
vibrating at this concept what is the
field it's a
bunch of values okay
that uh get weaker and weaker
as they get radially away from ground
zero okay so we call that a field and
now they're going to vibrate these
numbers and they say well these fields
vibrate
and even with that they cannot explain
attraction because tell me how that
magnet attracts the other one that's
what i want to know okay
and so when we go and we look up mr
faraday and mr maxwell this is what they
tell us this comes from
faraday on the physical characters of
the lines of magnetic force that was
from 1852 he obviously was in
investigating magnetism since the 1830s
at least not earlier and he says i
cannot conceive curved lines of force
without the conditions of a physical
existence
in that intermediate space
what was mr faraday saying there's
something there that i cannot identify
it was a little too early for that right
bill gatey wasn't born then
and so uh he was trying to figure out
what was in that space
what did mr maxwell say he put this in
his book a dynamical theory of the
electromagnetic field he knew what a
field was was that region where
something is occurring but he says the
following field this is his definition
okay the space in the neighborhood of
the electric and magnetic bodies
in that space what
there is matter in motion
matter
in motion a field is a region where
there is matter in motion it's an exotic
type of matter no doubt about it but
it's in motion
and you say well bill is is that really
true is is is there something moving
in a field i mean the the iron filings
don't seem to move they just stick to
the magnet there's nothing moving there
so what do you mean
there's something moving in that
regional space like mr maxwell said okay
and here let's prove it you want truth
proof evidence okay let's let's do an
experiment here here we put a magnet
under water
we're going to put a magnet underwater
and you can see that each one of the
iron filings is drawn
individually one by one there is
something moving in that region called
field magnetic field here it is okay
look at that okay you can see the iron
valley is being pulled one by one
towards the magnet
something is twirling something is
moving in a region around the magnet and
we call that region we refer to that
region as a magnetic field but a
magnetic field is not a static
thing
okay what it is like mr maxwell said
there is matter in emotion
matter in motion you cannot avoid it
okay so uh what we need to do is
identify what
what what is that mother nature uses
because we're gonna unify remember
electricity with gravity we're gonna try
to figure out because what is uh
electricity what is magnetism well we
have electromagnetism
and electromagnetism as according to mr
hertz is what uh
you know builds the electromagnetic wave
known as light
so we have light in gravity and we have
to include electricity and magnetism
within that context okay
and
so here's an experiment that will in
addition unify
quantum mechanics with general
relativity because general relativity
again is the world of big quantum
mechanics is the world of small okay we
have the lunar ranging experiment done
for many years the project was
[Music]
shut down afterwards uh a couple years
ago i think here's the lunar ranging
okay and you have what you have you have
a laser pointed from the earth to a
retro reflector on the moon okay let's
do it with waves okay here we have the
electromagnetic waves what are you
staring at you're staring at vectors
that are moving what is a vector well
vector is just the magnitude and
direction
what are we talking about magnitude a
number so you're talking about five uh
whatever's and they're moving a given
direction that's what those
arrows represent a whole bunch of arrows
makes a field and a field makes light in
other words this laser made out of light
you're talking about uh vectors so what
are we talking about we're talking about
numbers this is a quantitative
description of what light is it doesn't
tell us what light itself is okay okay
let's do it differently let's do it with
particles here we go particles okay
okay so uh we go with particles um how
are you gonna unite because remember the
grand unified theory is about unifying
light with gravity okay we got light how
do you
unify that with gravity
i mean how does those particles that go
from the earth to the moon and back
after they hit the retro reflector how
does that produce
pull how does that produce
um
in
the uh
for the moon not to leave the solar
system that's the question you have to
answer
okay and there's a bigger problem also
with particles
in case you want to simulate light with
particles the laser with particles and
that's the fact that the moon is moving
see if the moon was standing still well
you can maybe still
say i shoot particles at the retro
reflector they bounce off they come back
to earth great now now let's move the
moon we're going to be moving the moon
now okay here it is and this is what
happens to the particles the particles
are going to have to describe
a curve
in space okay you can see how that goes
as the earth moves and moon moves
you have to shoot the particles where
the moon is going to be in the next few
seconds okay see it here
we've got 384 kilometers a thousand
kilometers that's almost one and a half
light seconds
okay so round trip you're talking about
almost three seconds
and by that time you know the earth is
traveling 30 kilometers per second
around the sun the moon is traveling one
uh kilometer per second around the earth
those are the speeds and so you just you
describe a curve
so here you're shooting these particles
at the retro reflector they have to
trace a curve through space in order to
hit the reflector to where the moon is
going to be in one second one and a half
seconds really and then it bounces back
and where to where the earth is going to
be
in uh in three seconds later
yeah sure uh what is this ping pong
okay you see the problem you gotta shoot
the particles where the moon is going to
be even if it's just a
a relatively short distance again you're
not you're not supposed to point it
directly at the retro reflector that's
my point okay so this is the problem
with that okay that with particles
but again even if you use particles or
waves that's great for light now unify
that with gravity because that's what
the gut is the gut is the grand unified
theory okay
and so uh yeah we do it with ropes this
is the way uh science does it rational
science okay we have the laser there
and what you have is actually ropes we
put only one rope obviously we're
talking about gazillions of ropes here
but we put one rope and you can see
what's happening uh
nothing goes anywhere
all you have is a rope tying your laser
directly to the retro reflector and back
all it does is twirl in place we receive
the signal at the atom that receives the
thump
okay
and what happens well let's move the
moon around what happens when we move
the moon now well you can see what
happens you have all these uh
ropes electromagnetic ropes twine
threads every atom from the moon is
connected to every atom of the star of
the earth and so both of them can move
anywhere they want light will never get
lost because light can only travel along
a rope what is light uh just a torsion
of the rope it's not even any traveling
that's why it's so fast you know just
twirl a rope
in place and you'll find out that the
signal travels you could say
instantaneously that's how fast
light is 300 000 kilometers per second
you can only explain it with something
like a rope
okay a
twine pair of threads a dna like rope
then you can explain the speed
okay so here we have an astronaut and
he's falling to earth
okay here he goes
he's falling to earth how are you going
to explain this
and again remember that you not only
have to explain it you have to do two
things
you're going to be uniting light with
gravity okay here we have gravity you
say well he falls to earth because of
gravity great we have no explanation
what we have is a description we're
saying that's gravity that did it
okay
so let's do it with force which is what
quantum mechanics would propose you know
that's what uh newton proposed he says
there's a force
okay so let's go with the force here's
the force
force is pushing him down
so we have a concept called force and
it's pushing
the astronaut down towards the earth
great we're going to learn a lot with
that the word force you know all you can
do with force is describe you have an
equation you say force is equal to
gravitational constant g times mass
times mass divided by distance squared
that's just the description a
quantitative description so far you
haven't explained anything so by saying
force you're only giving me a
mathematical description
okay let's replace that now with
particles how do we do it with particles
here's the astronaut being pushed by
particles
right so we have all these particles
everywhere what's the mechanism
and even if you have a mechanism you can
tell me how the uh
astronauts being for example pushed by
all these particles tell me how that
relates to light because remember you
have to unify light with gravity we have
gravity but where's the light
okay so that's the problem there and how
do they do it in uh
uh general relativity well there is a
little scary okay here it is okay we
have warped time okay and there you have
warp time
okay the guy just slides uh down that
canvas
bumpy ride there
okay what the hell is that how do you
explain
that the astra falls to earth because
you know there's this canvas
made of time
and it's waving around because you have
to have waves remember you have to have
gravitational waves
how does that relate to anything
and there you have the waves okay
how do we do it with uh ropes with
science with the rope hypothesis very
simple every atom in the
uh of the astronaut is bound to every
atom on earth as he gets closer to the
earth the ropes fan out
period we're done baby stuff you don't
need to go to college to understand this
well unless unless you've been
brainwashed by the system but otherwise
you if you were an eight-year-old boy
you would say well i understand this is
straightforward you know
every atom in his body is connected to
the earth as he gets closer the ropes
fan out that gives you the acceleration
known as uh gravity here on earth
obviously in on the moon you would go at
a different rate and so on in the sun as
well
okay so you can see the comparisons
between the establishment what we
propose here
here's another one here's the spoon we
let go of the spoon now we're on earth
we're no longer out there in space so
we're going to be looking at quantum
mechanics or
you could say
uh
classical mechanics if if that's what
you uh vouch for okay what the gd fan
here we have a spoon it falls to the
floor okay so we say why did that spoon
fall to the floor
okay so what are we gonna do use green
pixies as this fella suggested we're
gonna have all this uh green pixies push
the spoon downwards
and then uh what do we do with the green
pixies on the other side of the planet
uh when the chinese man uh let's go the
spoon the pixies moving the opposite
direction
i mean you know uh this is kind of uh
very specific you're saying here it does
but then how does it do it on the other
side of the planet okay
how did we do it in science well very
simple if every atom of the spoon is
bound to every atom on earth as the
spoon falls to the floor
the ropes fan out see how easy it is to
understand the mechanism now whether you
believe in this or not that's your
personal opinion what we're saying here
i'm giving you a mechanism that you can
sink your teeth into you know the other
ones can't give you a mechanism and
that's why mathematical physics doesn't
deal with mechanisms and dismisses them
as what as philosophy
okay uh so here's uh here's what you got
to do this is your homework okay if you
want to do the gut the grand unified
theory this is what you're tasked with
you have to unify particles with waves
what are waves bunch of vectors that are
moving very scary stuff what is a vector
magnitude and direction and they have
these magnitude and directions moving
sideways perpendicular to the direction
of the vectors
and there you have particles you can
assume that they're anything you can
assume that they're electrons if that's
what you want photons uh virtual photons
maybe tachyons whatever you want to put
in there i don't care
please unify these two
proposals how are you going to unify
them
and so what they do is they elude the
visualization because they cannot even
visualize it in fact uh for the wave
packet uh who was it uh roger penrose
nobel prize what did he draw in his book
two books by the way he drew a corkscrew
because he had no idea how to how to
illustrate a wave packet okay
just a bundle of energy but this is what
you gotta do you have to
unify the particles with the waves is
there something you can do there
physically
absolutely not mathematically which is
the
equation they're searching for i don't
know i mean
first of all we don't care even if they
find an equation but i doubt very much
you can find an equation that can unify
um first the particles with the waves
and then gravity with light
in other words quantum mechanics and
general relativity
okay um
yeah how do we do it in science and real
science well here we have it put it over
here
see how easy it was
there it is you have two atoms they're
bound by what we call the
electromagnetic rope a dna like
mediator
and what it does is it twirls around it
it torques
and it's these torsions that
thump
the atoms to which they're connected
and you receive the same the the light
that comes from the other atom and the
other guy received the light comes from
your atom that's what's happening that's
why it's almost instantaneous when that
happens
okay
okay and um
so
give me a second here
give me a second i'll be back in a
second
okay i'm back uh
[Music]
this is what you what we are trying to
do here we're trying to unify it in
mathematics right uh what they're trying
to do is unify
newton's gravitational equation together
with einstein's field equation okay
this essentially what it is for gravity
even if you could unify those
you could say that newton's
gravitational equation is
uh
einstein's equation uh at the limit when
it stands still when everything's
standing still okay
but that that can be done okay but look
at the mechanisms what does newton
propose well he's suggested force and he
he mediated that in his mind with
particles
on the other hand uh look at einstein
what did he propose warp time
and i'm not sure how you can unify warp
time with particles okay
that's the problem there so the
unification of the equations could be
one thing that might be achievable what
you cannot achieve is the unification of
the mechanisms
and then unifying this with light
well good luck with that one you know uh
both uh from from the point of view of
equations which at least quantum
mechanics has been unable to do
but for sure you cannot unify light with
gravity out there in you know in in
space
i mean what you're gonna have to do is
explain why the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system because it's held by
what we call gravity to the sun
what's that got to do with light
and that's where the problem is they
cannot unify these two
mechanisms to begin with let alone the
discrete the mathematical description
and here we have um
another problem we're going to throw on
top of that because you have the gravity
waves okay remember uh a couple years
ago they proved that two
black holes collided and they were able
to pick up the gravity waves from those
two black holes
the waving of what
and then
this is the issue the issue if gravity
is made of waves of some kind of waves
how does that pull if a wave is an
outward mechanism i mean a wave is you
throw the
stone in the pond
the waves the ripples go outwards from
where the stone fell
and so let's throw three stones in space
here we go
okay here's the stones from the black
holes right we'll call those the stones
and they create these waves and the
waves move outwards
but then you have waves moving out from
another pair of black holes and from
another black hole so these waves move
outwards please tell me please explain
to me give me a mechanism of how this
these waves that go outwards pull on
each other how do these waves from one
pair of black holes air pull
on the waves created by another
pair of black holes in other how do they
pull on the other black hole
they're all going outwards
so the mechanism is irrational totally
irrational you cannot visualize this
so whatever they proved
nasa again or all these groups that are
out there these think tanks they go out
there and they say look we've proven it
we've uh we were able to detect
gravitational waves
yeah so those were the waves coming
towards us how do those pull us
how do you know their gravity waves
that's the issue
and so yeah
mathematical physics does not have
mechanisms and so the question is if
they're describing something out there
how valid is their description if they
don't know if it's a bird you know a
plane or superman i mean first you gotta
determine that before you can you know
put an equation to it
to have just a value and say look we
know how fast it goes but we don't know
what it is that's moving you know maybe
it's the what the
uh tasmanian devil that i showed earlier
okay maybe that's what's moving you
gotta identify that first
okay so here are the problems okay uh
with uh brand unified theory and it's
the grand unified mechanism the problems
theorists must solve okay at least from
a physical point of view that's what we
talk about here uh first we have to
distinguish between explanation and
description
we have to distinguish between mechanism
and equation equations just a
description a
quantitative description a mechanism is
something that you can just watch
you know you want to know how the window
broke okay you see the stone goes
through the window we're done we know
how the window broke that's what we want
to see something as simple as that
kindergarten stuff that's what mother
nature understand mother nature never
went to school she never learned math
we invented the math as a description a
language of descriptions for what mother
nature does and the only thing we can
describe is you know what we can see we
cannot describe or you know quantify
that which we cannot see so we we need
to know
you know what what's in that invisible
world that's what we need to detect uh
elucidate
and uh so what's the problem the issue
is that you have to explain action at a
distance specifically in the case of mag
well both magnetism and specifically uh
gravity okay action at a distance are
you going to do with particles
because this is what
quantum mechanics uses even though the
particles of quantum mechanics ain't
particles
the particles of quantum mechanics are
wave function collapses
that's what they are they have a wave
function collapses it turns into a
particle and they call that a
a particle so it's a concept that
collapsed
and uh good luck with that one no wonder
they can't they haven't incorporated
gravity into the
standard model of quantum mechanics
waves okay waves are upward mechanisms
but what are waves they're a bunch of
vectors
so i guess that's the end of that
i mean you cannot explain a physical
mechanism with outward going waves and
for sure you cannot explain attraction
with waves going outwards
and then you have the rope
so that's something for you to consider
if you want to pull on the donkey
you better have an elongated
entity a mediator between your hands and
his neck
okay so i don't care if you use a rod i
don't care if you use a chain
coaxial
wire whatever you want to use but it
better be elongated
it must reach from your hands all the
way to donkey then you can explain pull
if you do not put a mediator
you are
in effect right
uh doing black magic you're explaining
with black magic you're saying that you
move here your hand
and somehow by remote control the donkey
moves towards you
yeah sure
and uh so yeah you have to reconcile
waves with particles you have to
reconcile push with pull
that's that's what essentially the gut
is
and uh again you can't do one-way
mechanisms because they don't attract
and you have to deal with especially
intangibility and invisibility your task
is to determine to tell me
what it is that is in that space between
your hand and the donkey between the
earth and the sun
uh between the earth and the moon
between the andromeda galaxy and the
uh
milky way galaxy why are we pulling on
the adrenaline against the galaxy how
are we doing that what is the mechanism
that's the issue and if you can figure
that out hey you get a noble for
discovering the gut
okay because that's what they're that's
what the goal is that's the holy grail
the grand unified theory of mathematics
okay we had some moonies the other day
and they had uh some
points they raised what is a mooney well
ammonia is a person who believes that uh
humans never stepped on the moon okay
so we have these moonies and
um
i can only tell you that you know they
gave me a little tinge of doubt
when i found out uh how neil armstrong
answered
in that uh
he gave uh there was a um
a uh what is it
conference and he talked to
all the
people from the press okay
and
he was not very gung-ho about him
having stepped on the moon that made me
wonder about neil armstrong you know i
thought that was kind of strange
but uh just because he was strange it
doesn't mean i'm gonna throw the baby
with the wash water you know doesn't
mean i'm not gonna believe that man did
not go to the moon
and i'm saying that the best way to deal
with this subject for people who are
rational on both sides of the issue
because there are people who simply
don't believe but i think they are quite
rational anyways but this is the issue
the issue is
why don't we
sink our teeth into something that we
can all verify to some degree
and that is the iss the international
space station is flying around 15 times
a day every hour and a half around the
world
okay
and anyone who's got a pair of
binoculars or a telescope should be able
to
follow the path that is published by
nasa and locate that thing up in the air
okay you should be able to focus
especially on a clear day you should be
able to focus and see the iss out there
now if you can focus your binoculars or
your telescope on the iss you'll realize
that that is a big monster you know this
is not a little 2x4 toy that they sent
out it's not a little balloon
you're talking about a monster
out there that's flying around the earth
and so the question is how did they put
that thing up there
did they take uh one day just said they
had a headache and they said why don't
we send a rocket with all this stuff up
there is that how they did it
no there had to be steps
many steps before they could build that
thing up there
this monster
and make it orbit around the earth
and if we have the technology to send
piece by piece up there over a period of
10 years build the iss up there and make
it orbit the earth
then uh you have to say well it's not
all fake news okay
it's not like you should believe
anything you should throw the baby out
with the wash water there is something
out there and we have to identify it if
you identify it you have to believe that
there were steps
that humans took to get that thing up
there in the air
okay so one fall says uh
it says that we could reproduce some of
this stuff in hollywood okay so he says
the following jfk boldly proclaimed to
the world the u.s would successfully put
a man on the moon and return himself
return him safely to earth before the
end of the decade
the 60s right
and he did it okay or apparently that
was the goal right charged with
executing that mission it would be a
dereliction of duty not to game out what
failure might look like
dead u.s astronauts orbiting the moon on
or earth for decades is a scenario to be
avoided at all costs
okay he says if the best in the 1960s
had the know-how to put a man on the
moon
hollywood's best of the uh era could
realistically recreate the successful
mission always have a plan b
yeah i'm not saying that you could not
reproduce this in hollywood maybe not at
the time i'm not so sure they could
reproduce what i showed the other day
which was buzz buzz aldrin you know
flipping uh uh what was it a flashlight
around i'm not sure they could have done
that in
1969 in hollywood or in the best of
studio on earth but let's concede it
let's forget about challenging let's
concede it i said it the other day uh
everything that we've done on the moon
can be
just as well be done in hollywood we're
done uh i'm on record okay
so how do you distinguish the real thing
from the fake one how do you distinguish
uh whether it was done in hollywood or
whether it was done on the moon
and the answer is you probably can't
not today at least especially you know
when you look at everything in
retrospect and so all you could have is
some
some conspiracy theories saying well the
government's fooling us they did this
they did that why did they hide this why
did the tapes disappear and why is the
shadow here wrong and you can do a
million
analysis okay
and the question is you're always going
to end up with the same
answer the answer is we could have just
as well done it in hollywood as on earth
and
does that
mean that we did not
go to the moon
so that's a question for you to ponder
okay here's a another he put the
columbia impersonators colombia was the
one that blew up in the air okay up
there never made it and all these people
they say are still alive
they got their names
uh they say their faces are very similar
and so this is what they put out
and so yeah all you can do is talk about
conspiracies that's about it um this
does not prove anything but this is what
people
dwell upon you know they say uh oh i saw
this person again they think this is
like uh 9 11 where uh some of the pilots
ended up being alive in saudi arabia you
know and then the u.s government said
well uh same name
okay also a pilot you know just by
sheriff's a very common name like smith
you know
okay i don't know
um a lot of this stuff is fakery on the
people who actually put the pictures out
there but people never investigate where
the pictures came from
and so you know what have we learned we
haven't learned anything just by looking
at these pictures and saying oh they're
still alive are you sure or are you
going to believe
the guy who put the pictures out there
did you ask him where he got him
i mean you know you can go on and on
okay another foul says
the iss we see something in the sky sure
but how can we verify what it is okay
let's start with its altitude how do we
do that i don't think people deny that
you see something the thing in question
is if the thing you are seeing is iss
where the iss footage is recorded from
or i guess he was asking a question
there i guess anyways he says which is
highly unlikely as it's kind of
demonstrated that they are mixing
several different techniques together
and again all i can tell you is
uh
you know is there an iss first of all
please verify that first before you open
your mouth because
we can talk all day about you know
conspiracies
and we're not interested in that per se
the first thing we want to establish is
there an iss to begin with out there
that everyone can verify at home or
maybe with some friend who's got a
telescope or whatever you can verify
this and if it's out there
you got at least you you you block that
base you say i covered that base okay so
it see it's either out there or it ain't
one of the two it can't be both okay and
that's something anyone can verify out
there without you know just spinning
their wheels
and so this is where i ask people to
start start by saying is there an iss if
there is we can go to the next step and
say are there people in the iss are they
floating around and here's that one
who's dead set against that he says
there's a problem with safety especially
you know with a
lady there who let go of the bubble of
water
and then she swallows it and this fella
says oh how could you do that that's so
dangerous it could kill them all and
another person says you know i think
it's this one also uh says that you know
someone could perforate you know one of
these stones that the sun throws at us
together with the solar wind and throws
the stones at us it goes right through
the iss and suddenly you have a leak and
these people are even without helmets in
there they would instantly die why would
they be without helmets without
spacesuits without anything inside
inside the iss when it's so dangerous
when anything can go wrong you know and
it says how long do the astronauts have
to get into a pressured suit if the iss
has a leak
in other words let's let's say something
suddenly punctures the iss
do they have time to put their helmets
on and all this in fact i think when
they sleep they even take their suits
off you know they they kind of sleep
standing up you know
obviously we don't know however there is
a person who decided to discuss the
issue the issues of pressure and
possible failures with anyone who wanted
to listen he was quite firm that there
was something amiss with the safety
procedures on the iss
okay um
do you put a helmet on or even a
parachute when you go on an airplane i
mean you know something anything can
happen on an airplane effect i think
it's more likely to happen on an
airplane than out there in space where
you have um you're almost well you've
got a lot more vacuum up there right
you're in a level of vacuum much higher
than the earth so here on earth you know
just about anything can hit a plane in
fact there's been planes that have been
hit by birds flock of birds that went
into the engines you know they've had
all kinds of problems with birds uh but
anything can you know a stone out of
nowhere you know volcano maybe erupting
somewhere and throws a stone at the
airplane suddenly it goes at such speed
that it punctures
you know the wall of the airplane are
are you
prepared
to put a helmet on or are you going to
wait for the mass to come down or you
know i mean what what procedures are
there
and again i'm saying that you know the
likelihood of likelihood of that
happening
is so remote that i don't think the
astronauts have to worry about it
especially about drinking water you know
a bubble of water floating around
someone in there said you know it's
incredible that she would have that you
know it could oxidize the the wires and
everything i mean come on
what are these people thinking about
okay and then another fellow talks about
the construction of the iss yes the iss
is a is the biggest marvel construction
of humankind and no video evidence of
its construction exists
first of all they built it over 10 years
that's the official version you don't
have to believe it maybe it's fake news
but that's that's what they say it's
built over 10 years i'm not sure they're
going to take the trouble to go up there
and with a camera
and say okay joe uh what are you gonna
put today i'm gonna put the left wing
okay so they put the left wing and the
guy films it then the next day they do
something else then then you have to
think about you know the fact that they
took a lot of these parts with the
shuttles so the shuttle went up there
took the part and then came down
and so they're gonna film every little
trip up there for every little part that
they built on the iss
i mean i don't i don't think so i don't
think i
i don't know i'm not sure it's uh
at least i i don't think it's an
argument against the building of the iss
but yeah maybe there is maybe some part
was filmed i don't know
maybe there is a film of one of the
parts or maybe the
uh original part that they put up there
i can't tell you
but i don't think it denies that there's
an iss up there again don't don't tell
me how it was built tell me if there is
something up there to begin with because
if there ain't
then we don't have to worry about uh
anything related to the iss
okay another file says show me a full
orbit of the iss uninterrupted film from
on board
he wants the guy 24 hours or i'm sorry
it'd be an hour and a half because it's
every 15 minutes and the guy filming
around right
well we could do that in hollywood in
fact they did say
that uh the
apollo 11 trip
was phil i mean one of the arguments out
there one of the theories you know uh
one of these
people who objects who thinks it's uh
hoax
they said that it was filmed in houston
where they have this globe that they
made of the moon
which they built exactly like the moon
with all the surface features etc which
they uh filmed when we sent the lunar
orbiters up there so we filmed that from
everywhere from every side we filmed the
moon even from the dark side
they built this globe which is an exact
replica uh you know of the moon
and they could have filmed there as well
so we can do the same thing with the
earth i'm sure
we can film all around the globe
uh that we have in front of us and say
oh this is from the iss
so i mean how can you tell the
difference between the guy who films it
from the iss and the guy who films it
here on earth i mean would that prove to
him that there is an iss out there
okay so again you know
a lot of these arguments
uh don't hit the mark they don't hit the
mark because i think what you got to do
is first determine whether there is an
iss floating up there you know orbiting
the earth and if there is one well at
least we we covered first base then the
next question is maybe you know another
of the questions would be are there
people working in there floating around
in uh not zero gravity because you still
have gravity but remember that thing is
you're floating in that thing because
again you have no no gravity against the
walls or anything you're not kicked
around okay
so
again uh first let's determine those two
and then whatever argument you come up
with against apollo 11 having landed on
the moon the issue is
is there a difference can you tell me
the difference between landing on the
moon for real and doing it in hollywood
if you can tell me the difference hey
i'll give you a million bucks i'll buy
you a beer okay
if you can't tell me the difference well
then you don't have an argument against
the
fact that we did not
land on the moon
okay let's move on to the questions
people made and some of them were
related to the subject matter i brought
up the other day which was a concept
what is a concept and we had all kinds
of questions on that here we have one
file says quote a concept is two objects
unquote
well not real that's not what i said
okay so he's putting words in my mouth
he's saying a concept is two objects now
i could have said that uh
off the cuff you know and so he took it
he just hung on every word
no i i made it clear uh what a
concept is it's a word that
invokes or embodies two objects okay
that's not exactly what he put there a
concept is two objects no not not true
okay so he said clearly you said
nonsense okay yeah if you put a
scarecrow there and want to knock it
down hey
uh knock yourself out maybe you meant
two objects in relationship to form a
concept okay again this spells uh
english is not
up to par okay not the best but his
understanding is even worse okay i took
an apple and i placed it on the table in
the kitchen then i took another apple
and placed it next to the first one now
i have two apples on the table i have a
concept of apples
okay he said relationship
concept uh synonyms that's what i'm
saying okay you can't you can't uh
the word concept is essentially a
synonym of relationship that's why you
need to have two objects and i use the
word vat
i showed that as a preposition
as a conjunction etc uh the word that
uh already embodies or implies
two objects a relationship between two
objects because when you talk about that
you're referring to
implicitly to this
the fact that two objects are or have a
relationship of connection of dependence
generates a or forms a concept
and here you have the definition okay
here's the definition concept a word
that invokes or embodies two objects or
two words treated as objects and i like
the example of the word universe which a
lot of people say oh a universe is a
thing
and when i tell them it's a concept they
say oh so we live within a concept and
so we have to answer this
for people to understand what we're
referring to here universe what is the
word matter and space so we're talking
about atoms and nothing
that's what universe is we're treating
nothing or space temporarily as an
object again two words treated as
objects here we're treating space as if
it were an object we're saying there's
matter or atoms and we have this other
thingy which is a
not non thingy and nothing but we'll
call it a thingy now we have two things
we have the atoms and we have nothing
object that which has which
that which has shape
we should take that dozen out that
anywhere that you can imagine so
whenever we say that we're referring to
any word in the dictionary what is
matter many objects that's what matter
is in space that which has no shape in
other words nothing so space is
momentarily treated as a container okay
and
of course it's not a container but we
treat it as if it were a container we're
treating it as an object so concepts
such as universe and space can be
neither finite nor infinite there is no
concept that has shape so you cannot say
that the concept in this case universe
or in this case space is a thing okay
so uh the word concept again uh a word
that embodies or uh in invokes two
objects it uh tacitly re alludes to two
objects
okay and here we have uh concept versus
the object okay we have this no concept
has shape
all concepts are relations they're
comparisons but made by whom by us by
humans
objects we point to concepts we define
okay so you don't define the word chair
you point to it and name it say chair
and now the e.t understands your
language okay the klingon knows what
you're referring to every time you say
chair okay you can't do that with
concept you can't point to energy you
can't point to
uh love
you can't point to mass
you can put to what has mass like the
elephant but you can't point to mass
itself can't point to weight okay
and uh objects have contrasts okay
concepts have antonyms
okay
concepts have synonyms and antonyms but
objects have contrast they have better
have contrast if it's an object and so
the question there what contrast are you
going to put for space what's outside of
space where the space end and whatever
continues that's what you get answered
and of course you can't do that with
space
space is the contrast to all objects
it's the contrast of all objects space
is also the name we give to the antonym
of object in other words nothing nothing
is the opposite of something when you
point to space the dark stuff there
between the earth and the moon right you
are implicitly treating space as an
object
okay so that's the context of the word
space
in the context of universe which is a
concept do we live
in a concept do we live within a concept
do we live in the universe the answer is
no we don't live in a concept we don't
live within a concept universe is matter
and space we form
we don't live in but we form part of the
matter of the universe we are made of
atoms just like everything else that is
made of something out there okay and so
uh we it's you can't say that we live in
the universe
we are the matter we form part of the
matter of the universe that's the way we
have to look at this and we are not
supposed to treat space or the universe
wrong to put an article in front of that
in uh in physics
but uh
we do not live within like if we're
inside a container
okay that's not the notion that we
should have of space or of the universe
the way we have to look at it is we form
the matter of the universe
okay here's another follow also relates
to the definition of concept concept
refers to those words terms and
prepositions which assist us in the
perception and description of the world
shapes colors quantities measures
temporal words positional words and
again all they do is copy and paste
where do they copy it from they copy it
from the ordinary dictionary this is not
a scientific definition so we cannot use
this in science first of all it's too
verbose too many words
and the more words you put in a
definition the easier it is to tear down
you know look at the word life which i
analyzed some time ago
and they say well if that which
reproduces which grows which ages et
cetera etcetera etcetera right
and so you know my grandmother doesn't
reproduce anymore
my aunt never reproduced were they alive
so you can see how easy it is to tear
definitions that have so many predicates
okay you got to make the definition as
short as you can and this one you can
see the word concept here it's got so
many
if hands and butts that
looks like one of those uh laws that
they make congress makes you know so
yeah this is no good you can't use this
definition easy to tear down
and again that's from ordinary speech
okay here's another file who gave it a
shot and i'm not sure he pulled it
out of a dictionary but it says kansa
means thought conceived by the mind love
that one because he says concept is
conceived
okay a concept is a conception okay good
love it
yeah you can't use synonyms to define
words and that's what all these people
do they never learn how to define words
scientifically the first thing you have
to avoid is antonyms and synonyms you
cannot say what's the definition of
horse well it's a not a dog and it's a
not a cat
it's not a fish
but yeah you're going to go through all
the animals in the universe
i mean you can't define things in the
negative okay
okay changing a little bit the subject
fellow talks about knowledge and belief
people don't like me saying that
knowledge is belief because it destroys
your religion so here it is he says no
equal belief completely wrong okay
wrong according to whom see wrong means
your opinion
what's wrong to you is right to someone
else to your neighbor okay so we look it
up knowledge what is it justified true
belief
big belief there what is justified also
belief justified means you you justified
it so justified by whom true according
to whom and believed by whom by the pope
i mean who
who believes that who justified it it
all comes down to believe
so when you know something for sure when
you are certain of it when you are
convinced it is nothing more than your
opinion
belief
keep that in mind knowledge is belief
there is no difference between knowledge
and belief
people want to think that they know
and again like i told this fellow i said
uh
nasa proved they know
to prove that through an experiment they
have to know right and the official
version is that earth when it spins
drags space and time around itself
okay they know it
and he said well i don't believe that
well what do you mean that's it's
knowledge they know it what do you mean
you don't believe it
yeah we all have problems with with
knowledge because you your knowledge is
different than my knowledge
okay here's another film that says all
objects have shape okay but not all
shapes are objects
well give me an example don't don't give
me a statement give me an example
show me a shape that is not an object
something that has shape that is not an
object and that's and of course if we
define objects as that which has shape
you're going to have a little trouble
with that okay all you're going to have
is an opinion
uh opinions yeah sure you might have
opinions and say
look
i don't think that a square
is an object
don't think a line is an object for
example or a point right
and uh i see something in front of me
it's got shape so yeah point line and
plane you could say i mean
something like a square or a circle yeah
they're objects they're objects because
they have shape and that's the
definition of object that which has
shape we're done
now
if you have a better definition start
with the definition and then
show me which uh like he says there not
all shapes are objects show me that your
definition
uh meets that criteria there okay that's
what you gotta do that's your homer
okay and uh here we go with uh another
one
says that science has all to do with
what with predictions okay let's find
out he says if science isn't about
making accurate predictions then science
is lame
and we should do it
okay let's not do science because
uh you know the mathematicians say it's
predictions and i'm saying that
predictions have nothing to do with
anything let me tell you why very simple
uh i make a prediction there's gonna be
um
uh what is it uh an eclipse tomorrow
okay
i make a prediction turns out that there
is an eclipse
so far all i did was give you a
description
now if i can explain
what cause or what the mechanism is of
an eclipse if i can explain to you
it means i have some experience with
eclipses where did i get this how did i
have
an explanation for it
well the explanation obviously is
because i had some experience with it
and experience explanations only have to
do with the past
okay it means i already saw the movie
at least in my mind you know i
visualized it
so
an explanation has nothing to do with
the future with predictions they're on
opposite sides of the
now of the line that divides the future
from the past
explanations belong exclusively to the
past predictions belong exclusively to
the future if you just do a prediction
all you did was describe if you can
explain why something is going to happen
it's because you have some
what was it called knowledge some belief
no some explanation
um you've already watched the movie you
visualized it and that means you have
some experience with it and that's the
past
so as long as you keep it to prediction
you're okay we won't hurt you as soon as
you give me an explanation of why you're
you're in trouble because now you're
talking about the past and not the
future
and so it's funny when the
mathematicians say we can predict
the uh original conditions of the big
bang
uh that happened went 12.8 billion years
ago
13.8 billion years ago yeah we can
predict yeah sure
okay and finally fell says he says i
recently saw an example in a video where
a scientist explained five different
methods of gravity to children of
different ages
she always said pull
but how the mechanism of pull works i
asked she didn't really explain
the children's brains were overwhelmed
trying to adapt to a non-visualization
the youngest ones didn't succeed but the
older ones had already adapted to the
non-visualization
they said like don't even waste your
time that's a tragedy because
visualizing is a human trait that we
have stored in our brains from our
earliest ancestors and this trait as i
said has been lost through school
yeah
see if if you teach a child to visualize
instead of to read a book and say just
memorize what's on page 45 and you'll
it'll be on the test if you ask them to
visualize a mechanism they would learn
physics
because they would have to figure out
you know if they can't visualize that
then they have a problem and you say
look make a movie of it you know
make all these drawings you know uh
motion pictures you know make a lot of
pictures put them in motion
and and then he can visualize the
mechanism of whatever but if he just
reads
and memorizes or just listens to the
teacher
recites some poetry you know and he
memorizes that
well all he's doing is feeding his brain
on stuff that
later he can't come out of so easily
that's that's the effect of that yeah
you have to visualize especially in
physics if you cannot visualize in
physics
you do not have a theory theory of
physics is a mechanism and a mechanism
is done with objects and if there are
objects there should be no reason for
you not to visualize it make a movie and
visualize
with that i'll see you probably next
sunday folks and maybe i can get rid of
this stuff that i had in my chest by
then